back here in New York and for the first
time ever two women are leading the
largest fire and police departments in
the country the FDNY and the NYPD Laura
Kavanaugh became the city's first female
fire commissioner just last month she
was acting commissioner since February
she's also one of the youngest in the
Department's history and earlier this
year commissioner kushant Sewell became
the first woman to lead the NYPD and
just the third black commissioner in
NYPD history only on CBS mornings they
join us for their first joint interview
a good morning Commissioners yeah good
morning it's a big deal both your
positions I want to get to the historic
nature of them but first since we just
had this coverage out of Colorado
Colorado Springs this tragedy at an
lgbtq nightclub commissioner Sewell I'd
love to know are there threats that
you're monitoring right now in the New
York City area anything that happens
across the country that horrific we
Monitor and we want to make sure that we
have our Assets in place to be able to
offer comfort for our communities we've
had some incidents in Hell's Kitchen
which are causing I'm concerned that we
have a number of resources devoted to as
well so we work well with our
communities we want to make sure that
they're safe and we certainly believe
that we have the resources to be able to
do that all right let's talk about the
work and the resources you to oversee
budgets in the billions tens of
thousands of people 30 000 officers uh
tens of thousands of of fire uh Fighters
as well as EMTs EMS inspectors what is
what does it mean starting with you uh
commissioner Kavanaugh what does it mean
to you to be in this role the first
woman to hold the position yeah I mean
it means a lot to me you know I hope to
inspire other people to see themselves
in positions that maybe they had never
thought of before I hope it opens the
door yeah what I think is fascinating
about you commissioner Kavanaugh I I
emcee to think for the fire department
and all the guys at the table were
telling me she's acting but she should
for sure have this job and what I
learned is that you went there on a
temporary basis commissioner Kavanaugh
you were only supposed to be there where
did you come from you're only supposed
to be there for a short period of time I
was in the mayor's office about eight
years ago so and we should also point
out just to clarify here I mean 98 of
the fire department is male right and
about 80 percent of the NYPD not the
leadership not anymore not anymore and
commissioner so how does it feel to to
thrive and be respected
um in such a male dominated industry I
keep saying that I think we need to
begin to normalize women in these roles
while these appointments are historic
and we don't take them lightly the work
we do is what matters and uh there we
cannot be the last in these roles um but
believe me I I think every single day
the men and women of the NYPD they are
truly extraordinary and the fact that
we've been able to uh get the support
that we need to do our job means a great
deal do you feel added pressure either
of you because you know people are
watching because of your gender because
of your race in your particular case do
you feel added pressure I would say not
pressure the spotlight yeah that's
definitely all the time it is bright and
it is hot at times yeah commissioner
Kavanaugh to get into a policy question
here scooters are all over these
electric scooters all over New York City
they're all over cities across the
country and there's been a bunch of
fires tied to them I think six people
have died according to your department
they've been more than 200 fires uh do
they need to be regulated in a new or
stronger way so we're working with the
mayor's office and the federal
government to actually look at exactly
that and the federal government actually
recently recalled a number of items that
we had pointed out so definitely we're
looking at better regulation and
commissioner Kavanaugh you you have not
been you were not a firefighter and some
people were thinking how can she run the
fire department if she hasn't been a
firefighter you don't see that as a
detriment though to what you do I don't
you know I'm I run big things my
benefits are most of my career and there
are a lot of people who run these
organizations who don't come up the
ranks you know they're huge
organizations I think of myself as an
advocate for our members and a CEO of a
large corporation commissioner so um
Tony mentioned headlines you know the
safety of people here in New York City
comes to mind especially in the subway
what are some of the things that you
might be heading to help people feel
safe in the city we all know the subway
is a lifeblood of the city we all depend
on it I took a Subway myself as a child
we recognized there were some challenges
in the subway so we surged thousands of
officers into the subway in cooperation
with our partners in the MTA we've
started making announcements on the
train to let people know that there are
police officers riding the trains and
their police officers on the platform
also when the train pulls into a station
where there is a Transit District you
will know that because there's going to
be an announcement that says that we
recognize that people feel safer when
they see an NYPD uniform the people just
completely exhale when they see a police
officer so having that omnipresence
having those people in the subway and
the officers engaging with the public is
important are there a lot of plain
clothes people on the subway there are
people you do not see in uniform okay
that's very good to know I've heard you
say uh commissioner Sewell that this is
a full circle moment for you because you
know they describe this as one of the
hardest jobs on the planet you call it
full circle but you can't imagine was it
something that you sought as a young
police officer did you seek this
position I thought the next thing
whatever the next thing was whatever the
next test was whatever the next
challenge was I was up for it and I
think both of us are about for this
challenge those lights may be hot but
we're ready for them oh and and
commissioner Kavanaugh you said you only
came there temporarily for the fire
department eight years later you were
still there why did you still stay what
is it that attracted what did you like
about it I mean it really is such an
amazing organization you know the men
and women who do this work are so
extraordinary you see it in some of
these recent events the roof rope rescue
a couple weeks ago I think you can
understand why if that's what you see
every day no matter how hard the day in
the office they inspire me they keep me
going and did you two know each other do
you hang out and say God can you believe
what is happening did you two know each
other we did not know each other before
this journey but we have become friends
since yeah all right I would love to be
a conversation I'd love to sit down at
lunch with the two of you I think that
could be really nice yeah that's a yes